the war on work that's the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
all right the left ruins everything it
touches they go soft on criminals they
villainize law enforcement now we have a
major police officer shortage across
america
they let left-wing nut bags run our
schools then they institute vax mandates
they go soft on student discipline and
now we have a major teacher shortage in
america
congratulations
today we learned that two million
students have left the public school
system all together between 2020 and
2021 that is staggering
and it's not just that nobody wants to
work in these toxic environments fewer
people want to work at all
and again thanks to the left liberals
loved remember the covet lockdowns
they're paid to do nothing loved it
ordering from ubereats zooming happy
hours playing online games like whiplash
or warzone binge watching tiger king on
netflix that was fun so many people were
vegging out in front of the screens for
so many hours a day they even had a name
for it
corn stream
and they marveled at how wonderful a
near total economic stoppage was for the
climate
if there is a silver lining to this
crisis it's visible in the skies above
china falling pollution levels brought
about by lockdowns may have
been shining an impact on sunshine wild
animals are now roaming city streets how
do we make sure these pollution levels
don't rebound
all right the branch cavitieans they
wanted to change the american psyche and
in many ways they succeeded
students are suffering from lost
learning and new anxieties
employers are suffering because they
can't find workers and many of those who
do show up they're not happy
i recently learned about this term
called quiet quitting where you're not
outright quitting your job but you're
quitting the idea of going above and
beyond you're still performing your
duties but you're no longer subscribing
to the hustle culture mentality that
work has to be your life the reality is
it's not and your worth as a person is
not defined by your labor
he's oozing masculinity
maybe it doesn't define you work but
your paycheck should maybe be defined by
how much you work
but prolonged coveted shutdowns and
liberal work from home policies they
gave a lot of workers the notion that
staying home was now their right and who
can blame them
after all nancy pelosi speaker pelosi
the ultimate queen of entitlement and
privilege she's allowed house members to
vote from home since the spring of 2020.
this proxy voting scam was supposed to
expire last week but all nan just
extended it for the 18th time
of course because of the public health
emergency that same emergency of course
didn't stop her from traveling to taiwan
or to italy and it's certainly not
dangerous enough to cancel that
congressional baseball game
i love baseball where season ticket
holders have been forever and this game
is so great and people are so nice
that's what makes it great but we're
competitive and it's great to be here
have a little fun
well we were hoping for the mass there
but no luck just when pelosi had her
beauty parlor opened for her blowouts
during the lockdowns remember rules and
expectations do not apply to them
do you think that any of your colleagues
are using proxy voting as an excuse to
get out of showing up to work no i don't
think so you know august is usually a
time for us to be in our districts
beyond clodell's and or you know if we
choose to take a vacation with our
families or something like that august
is usually the time for that that stuff
is usually planned way in advance so i'm
sure there were many
things that people couldn't reschedule
oh that's why we're doing it for the
last two years yeah what an example
these people are setting for america
grocery store workers airline employees
they have to show up
but the people's representatives can't
be bothered
the swamp strikes again
oh and federal workers you're going to
be shocked to know this i know they
don't want to show up either the office
of personnel management even pushed
telework and their recent guidance
opm doesn't care about how telework
affects the people who are paying the
actual bills though that's you
have you tried to call what a medicare
office lately questions about your
passport renewal
nightmare stories there but again
remember the bright side
if no one commutes the planet's going to
be cleaner yay
but the progressives didn't anticipate
the unintended consequences of their
green giddiness here
what did they think was going to happen
to subways and urban life when fewer
people actually commute into the cities
even a small dip in ridership on the
subway could send mass transit into
bankruptcy
there's also a sociological aspect to
the sweden-like obsession with work-life
balance says cultural observer malcolm
gladwell
it's very hard to feel necessary when
you're physically disconnected i know
it's a hassle to come to the office but
like
you know if you work if you're just
sitting in your pajamas in your bedroom
is that the work life you want to live
if we don't feel like we're part of
something important what's the point
it's not you're not just doing this to
get a p if it's just a paycheck then
it's like then you what have you reduced
your life to
but the left just refuses to think about
any of this in a rigorous way
they just declared that a four day work
week is smarter and better for the
climate
but if they stop to ask that with more
long weekends won't americans just
choose to travel more how is that good
for the planet
the fact of the matter is what they
really want really want
is for businesses to have no choice
eventually
the angle could see government mandates
that force workers to stay home or at
least a certain percentage of them
fake crises will be cited as a reason to
take away your freedoms here it's a
climate emergency it's a racism
emergency it's a health emergency
if it means making you poorer or
lowering your standard of living
gutting america's productivity so be it
it's not like the elites are going to be
inconvenienced by any of it
what they've done to our public schools
or public safety our borders and our
energy independence
they've done to our american work ethic
but we can turn this around we have to
by refusing to sit back and wait for
someone else to do the hard work of
saving what we love about america
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else